voilà pour ce documentaire delphine
horvilleur madame le rabbin n'hésitez
pas à réagir sur le hashtag docu débat
delphine horvilleur qui est avec nous
merci d'être là sur ce plateau à vos
côtés un habitué du docu débat odon
vallet historien des religions bonjour
en face de vous alice chablis bonjour
vous êtes co auteur de ce déni enquête
sur l'église et l'égalité des sexes chez
bayard et enfin à vos côtés fariba
hachtroudi bonjour merci d'être là vous
êtes romancière essayiste présidente de
l'association mosane hachtroudi
bienvenue à tous sadafi norville heures
avant de devenir rabbin vous avez
envisagé de devenir médecin
et puis vous avez été journaliste et des
professions où les femmes sont de plus
en plus nombreuses mais quand on a
longtemps considéré comme des métiers
d'hommes dans le documentaire vous dites
la médecine et journalisme sont au coeur
de la fonction rabbinique est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ça il me
semble souvent quand je dis que je suis
radin les gens s'imaginent que ça n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on était les
professions précédents tout ce qu'on
était des centres d'intérêt avant ça moi
j'ai l'impression que les morceaux du
puzzle en réalité s'imbriquent bien
mieux qu'on imagine ensemble disons que
ce que j'ai cherché dans mes études de
médecine ce que j'ai pu chercher dans le
journalisme c'est aussi ce que j'ai pu
rechercher dans la fonction rabbinique à
savoir la possibilité d'accompagner
d'écouter d'être témoin de l'expérience
sacré de mes pairs et de l'entendre elle
essayait de la retranscrire certaine
manière
donc j'ai l'impression que les choses
s'imbriquent alors bien entendu j'avais
pas pensé plus jeunes à la fonction
rabbinique tout simplement parce que je
n'avais pas de modèle autour de moi
vraiment de cette fonction moi j'ai
grandi dans un monde juif à ces
traditionalistes où il n'y avait pas une
possibilité d'envisager le rabbinat pour
les femmes alors il m'a fallu prendre
des virages mais qui m'ont nourri chacun
leur manière pour me mener vers cette
décision vos fidèles à la synagogue
est ce qu'ils ont déjà exprimé leur
sentiment sur le fait que le rabbin soit
une femme
est ce que certains ou certaines
viennent justement parce que vous êtes
une femme je crois il semble pour
beaucoup de gens à l'intérieur de la
synagogue maintenant c'est du domaine de
l'évidence ça fait maintenant quelques
années que ils ont l'habitude de voir
une femme officier
x men et des offices des conférences
enfin la fonction à binic rempli par une
femme à parité avec un homme parce qu'on
est une synagogue on est à la fois un
homme et une femme qui n'officie tour à
tour c'est devenu une norme je crois
pour les gens de la synagogue alors
certes parfois certains viennent me dire
que ils sont venus à moi spécifiquement
parce que il souhaitait poser telle ou
telle qu'elle soit une femme ou dans
l'idée que il leur serait plus facile
d'exposer telle ou telle problématique à
une femme est finalement c'est pas
toujours les questions qu'on attend moi
je me méfie toujours un peu de ses
clichés où on s'imagine que une femme
par essence et coûterait mieux entendre
et mieux serait nécessairement plus
proche de telle ou telle thématique
je crois que c'est pas toujours toujours
le cas moi je pense qu'au contraire
étudié enseigner mener des offices côte
à côte
hommes et femmes ensemble c'est le point
fort de nos communautés davantage que la
simple féminisation de la fonction alors
vous avez publié un livre qui s'appelle
en tenue d'eve sur la place de la femme
dans votre religion est votre
interprétation des textes
comment ils étaient accueillis dans
votre communauté il a été je pense bien
accueillie dans le contexte d'une
actualité qu'on connaît j'ai souhaité
écrire sur la question du féminin et de
la pudeur parce que c'est une obsession
qui est commune à toutes nos traditions
religieuses elle n'est pas propre au
judaïsme n'est pas propre non plus à
l'islam même si c'est souvent dans cette
tradition qu'on entend aujourd'hui
beaucoup parlé de la question de la la
pudeur des femmes je crois que tous les
discours religion ou leur coeur
particulièrement dans leur mouvance et
la sensibilité plus traditionalistes ou
parfois fondamentalistes une certaine
obsession du corps de la femme couverts
et il m'a semblé important d'explorer
cette problématique de l'intérieur même
du discours religieux pour essayer de
démontrer qu'en réalité bien entendu ce
qui est bien souvent ceux qui affirment
avoir une interprétation fidèle au texte
est bien bien souvent il s'en éloigne
est en réalité sont des textes
une lecture qui me semble très impudique
ceux qui sont bien souvent obsédé par la
pudeur mais femme est bien une lecture
très impudique de nos textes et c'est ça
qu'il faut réhabiliter aujourd'hui de
l'intérieur me semble-t-il des
traditions renard naviguer partager je
sais par certaines d'entre vous et on va
devenir très vite
vous dites que quand il ya des critiques
souvent elles viennent des femmes
comment vous le vivez sachant tout le
bien que vous leur voulait justement aux
femmes
c'est un phénomène qui me surprend et à
la fois que je comprends très bien les
critiques les plus virulentes que j'ai
pu entendre ces dernières années assez
systématiquement viennent de femmes qui
elles s'inscrivent dans un modèle très
traditionnel et le fait qu' une des
leurs une des femmes accèdent à une
fonction qui de leur point de vue est un
domaine réservé à l'autre au masculin ya
constitue pour elle une violence parce
que je crois que c'est une remise en
question beaucoup plus fondamentale que
pour les hommes
des attributs qui seraient les leurs ou
de la place qui leur serait un parti
donc j'ai effectivement cette habitude
maintenant de savoir que les les
résistances les plus fortes ne viennent
pas de là on attend elles viennent bien
souvent des femmes ça remet en question
quelque chose de très profond dans les
rôles importants à chacun et on va y
revenir
vos réactions à ce documentaire avait
mal tourné écoutez j'ai d'abord je suis
ravi si je peux féminiser le nom qu'une
rabin soit en face de moi ça ça vient de
mon vraiment les féminisation des noms à
mon avis sont très importantes mais bon
on par la littérature là et je pense que
c'est un combat fantastique c'est un
combat que pas mal de femmes ont essayé
de mener en iran l'iran un pays musulman
chiite et a été à la pointe de tous ses
mouvements depuis depuis au moins un
siècle et demi et je pense notamment à
lonato l'oeil noir et les roses le
soleil qui était une femme exégètes du
groupe du coran extraordinaire une
poétesse mystique fabuleuse on
l'appelait la mystique rouge les grands
voyageurs comme bobino l'appelait la
mystique rouge de lorient elle voulait
effectivement elle avait une relecture
du coran qui était fantastique et
qu'elle était dans l'ain dans un
mouvement le groupement du bob et qui a
elle a osé enlever son voile devant
mouvance et ses congénères en disant
c'est pas ça donc je veux dire c'est un
combat qui a commencé depuis longtemps
dans pas mal de pays
mais effectivement je pense en plus que
la france est une terre qui peut être
notamment avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment qui peut être porteur de ce
combat parce qu'il est très difficile
dans nos pays d'origine pour le moment
même si ce combat et continue et ça
continue en iran
aujourd'hui on reviendra peut-être donc
moi ma réaction c'est extrêmement
positif bien que je sois laïque est
totalement agnostique et vaud dans
l'allée du féminin dans les religion ou
confession est très compliqué
curieusement les deux religions qui ont
le plus de femmes dans le clergé sont le
catholicisme et le jaïnisme il y a deux
fois plus de religieuses catholiques que
deux religieux deux fois ils vont plus
le jeunisme génie une religion indienne
où il ya beaucoup plus de noms que de
moi mais dans les deux cas jaïnisme et
catholicisme ces femmes en ta statue
nettement inférieur alors les autres
religions c'est très compliqué oui il ya
des vénérables dans le bouddhisme dans
certaines branches du bouddhisme et dans
certains pays mais il ya d'autres pays
bouddhiste où il n'y a pas une seule
femme qui est un rôle important
si on prend l'hindouisme en principe les
brahmanes qui célèbre sont des hommes
alors il ya un cas qui est extrêmement
particulier c'est celui des religions
chamanique animistes ou bien souvent les
chamans parfois appelée médecine men ont
une bisexualité c'est à dire ils sont
supposés avoir les qualités les
attributs et les vertus des deux sexes
merci les temps tout dépend des pays si
vous prenez le protestantisme vous avez
des femmes pasteurs et même des femmes
évêques dont certains pays dans d'autres
pays en afrique c'est pratiquement
impossible qu'on soit pasteur protestant
ou prêtre anglican on doit être un homme
donc le conflit traverse toutes les
religions si vous prenez catholicisme il
est très probable que dans les premiers
temps du cas du christianisme il y avait
des diaconesses intègre femme diack
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas mais ça
pourrait l'être demain je pense que ça
peut beaucoup évolué d'une religion ou
d'une autre mais surtout d'un pays
un autre je pense que la civilisation et
la place que chaque civilisation en fait
à une femme c'est peut-être plus
important la limite que les religieux
alors en parlant dit vous avez écrit un
livre des funambules heures et vous
aussi alice châblis un livre qui
s'appelle le déni qui parle de la
domination la figure masculine sur la
figure féminine dans la religion
catholique
et vous ça a été moins bien accueilli
que le livre de delphine horvilleur vous
avez écrit sous pseudonyme
et puis vous dites on essaie de nous
faire taire est-ce que nous l
institution catholique et les médias
catholiques l'institution catholique les
livres dialogue que nous avons pu le
voir avec un évêque jésuites montrer
qu'effectivement ce livre doit être
black listé pour eux parce que nous
posons des questions qui sont des
questions taboues des questions qui
pourtant sont dans les têtes
allez les prêts pourquoi sont ils ne
sont ils pas mariés mais quand il va ils
ne sont pas prêts très il ya beaucoup
d'autres questions d'un hôtelier qui
nous ont servi d'ailleurs de fil
conducteur pour notre enquête c'est
vraiment une recherche que nous avons
fait en partant en fait on assiste de
retourner les choses pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi la situation était
si difficile dans l'église catholique
l'expérience de prendre la parole dans
l'église catholique franchement c'est
difficile
pourquoi et du coup on se dit on va
étudier tous ces textes d'hommes qui
font pendant mais un gros pendant parce
que c'est beaucoup plus important les
évangiles c'est des petits textes
il ya bien sûr l'ancien testament mais
et l'église catholique ça s'est
relativement peu et un énorme corpus où
il y a le droit canon le catéchisme de
l'église catholique et les thèmes du
magistère tout les ans ses cliques et
les paroles des papes et c'est un gros
recul alors ça que l'on pourra pas
revenir sur tout mais on va en parler
quand on regarde le documentaire donc l
on vous suit delphine horvilleur on voit
on sent à quel point ça vous tient à
coeur que votre religion soit vivante
que la synagogue soit un lieu de vie
vous donner du sens aux traditions
voudrait qu'on réécoute un extrait de
documentaire des débats politiques du
moment dans lequel nécessairement
voire au mieux nous sommes en a quelque
chose à dire mais va devoir se prononcer
et sur lesquels le monde religieux va
devoir réfléchir dans les mois à venir
des échéances politiques importantes qui
sont par exemple des réflexions maintien
de bioéthique en matière d'avenir de la
femme du statut de la famille de du
mariage homosexuel de la parentalité
homosexuels de l'acceptation de l'autre
il faut se nourrir dans nos tests nous
on est capable d'apporter des solutions
et des réflexions créative face à des
situations inédites que l'on rentre et
pour moi c'est ce qui fait qu'une
tradition religieuse est vivante et
qu'elle n'est pas un musée alors il ya
trois femmes rabbins en france des
femmes pasteurs aussi aucune femme
prêtre en france à l'étranger pareil je
les imams fariba hachtroudi vous
confirmer mais vous dites que en iran il
existe d ailleurs de la femme
il y à un mouvement qui se réclame qui
réclame 2 pour qui questionne qui est
qui interpelle le aussi bien le clergé
que le gouvernement pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs la femme
ça a commencé avec la fille d'un des
grands ayatollahs qui est qui est mort
qui était au début de la rue de la
révolution et il était progressiste par
rapport aux autres et on a même dit
qu'on l'avait tuée je n'en sais rien
elle est la pause est carrément la
question tant les renie et puis il ya un
mouvement je sais qu'il ya eu un
mouvement
j'ai lu des articles là dessus il ya
quelques années je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui où ça en est mais je sais en
revanche qui a vraiment un groupe de
femmes qui travaillent à au tex qui ont
pignon sur rue mais à l'intérieur de
leur maison et pour les femmes et pour
l'instant disons le clergé officiel
laisse ma patte leclerc il ya deux
clergé la loi élargit officielle et il
ya le clergé étatiques et ce n'est pas
pareil
mais je sais qu'à l'intérieur de
dès la dissidence du clergé en ce moment
en iran
il y avait des hommes des religieux de
haut rang qui sont pour la féminisation
de de l'islam en l'iran est également
pour que l'interprétation d'abord le
xterra de ce que ce que dont parlait des
c'est-à-dire de une une une
interprétation dynamique des textes mais
ça ça a toujours été dans les colonies
sans du monde absolument
ça a été toujours dans le mouvement
chiite beaucoup plus que le mouvement
sunnite mais également la féminisation
de l'islam et à a+ ses racines en iran
et dans d'autres pays
de shit disons de tradition chiite que
dans que dans le sunnisme
bon allez je vais me faire réagir à la
fois sur ce que vient de faire un gastro
dit mais aussi sur ce que vous dites
dans votre livre alice chablis que
aujourd'hui la position du pape
françois n'est pas très clair et vous
dit alice qu'il s'inscrit dans un
certain différentialisme homme femme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez au dollar
et c'est très compliqué parce que veut
dire la masculinité du clergé dans
toutes les religions est historiquement
lié au célibat il ya toujours eu deux
types de religion c'est à dire les
religions héréditaire et les religions
célibataire clergé héréditaire c'était
les cohanim dans le judaïsme antique et
ce sont les brahmanes dans le
l'hindouisme contraire il faut être
marier et avoir des enfants
on se met une charge verger célibataire
c'était effectivement le christianisme
en partie en partie et puis surtout le
bouddhisme bouddha n'a pas voulu de moi
de marier parce que disait-il
sinon les familles vont confisquer le
pouvoir il ya un vrai problème pendant
longtemps vous savez les pasteurs
protestants souvent et est passeur de
père en fils on trouve et qui confie
c'est un peu trop le pouvoir maintenant
c'est fini mais il faut trouver un moyen
pour que une femme puisse avoir le même
pouvoir hiérarchique qu'un homme
par exemple certaines confessions
protestantes elles peuvent être évêque
sans que pour autant on ne soit pasteur
évêque de mère en fille ou de père en
fils c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
compliqué mais après tous ces problèmes
cible et politique beaucoup plus le
pouvoir et économique et le noir
moi j'ai une question vous voir et je
pense que vous pourriez répondre mieux
que moi mais il me semble mon passé
d'archéologues me fait dire que depuis
qu'on a tiré d'ailleurs il ya des textes
anciens vous le connaissez mieux que moi
qu'on a tiré inanna dans les tréfonds
les ds dans lé monde d'en bas et que le
la religion a été confisquée par mardi
et les autres les dieux masculin je
pense qu'on a été on a dévié totalement
je vais revenir sur ce qu'est ce que
disait pardon delphine horvilleur vous
dites vous dites ces politiques mais
j'ai le pouvoir c'est le pouvoir s'il
est là c'est le pouvoir avec la
particularité que dans ce domaine de la
pensée religieuse
celui qui a le savoir a le pouvoir donc
pour avoir le pouvoir il faut avoir
accès au savoir donc tenir les femmes à
distance du texte et de l'interprétation
c'est la clé le moyen politique le plus
efficace mais ce que l'on aime tenir un
statu quo politique guinéenne oui les
défis ne se passe que également le dieu
et masculin je suis désolé c'est comme
ça on dit que robbie williams et l'on
parte en réalité il y a dans toutes les
traditions en tout cas moi je peux
parler de celles que je connais mieux le
judaïsme
il ya également des versions de lecture
notamment toute la tradition
cabalistiques
qui met en avant une féminité du divin
les objets lice on va trouver ses
traditions elles sont tout aussi
traditionnel elles sont subversifs dans
les deux sens du terme c'est à dire
qu'elles sont mal acceptée cacher et
elles sont des sous version on a voulu
les recouvrir d'autres choses deviennent
exigus l'udf il y avait 13 ans dans la
bible un dieu n'est pas sexuel
par contre il est plurielle dans un de
ces noms et leurs rimes et c'est très
particulier
alors maintenant il ya une chose qui est
vrai c'est qu'on a supprimé les déesses
féminine ça c'est tout à fait vrai cela
étant par exemple dans le catholicisme
il ya ce qu'on appelle une hyper du lit
du culte marial où marie devient une
quasi ds mais attention il ya un
archevêque de paris qui a même été
assassinés aux cris de à bas marie la ds
parce qu'il y avait le dogme de
l'immaculée conception
il faut faire très attention à ça mais
je suis d'accord avec vous on a supprimé
les déesses intention ni allah ni eux ni
dieu ne songe sexuelle oui allez chaabi
le contrôle du texte le contrôle de la
parole oui c'est le pouvoir et là c'est
sûr que les femmes dans l'église
catholique y sont interdites doumely est
interdit de lecture de logique dans les
célébrations et de célébration c'est le
théâtre qui organise les rapports de
pouvoir et les rapports entre hommes et
femmes
donc ça c'est clair mais l'église et je
pense les nôtres ce que vous représentez
en tout cas il ya une autre forme de
contrôle et de l'infériorisation des
femmes puisqu'il faut dire le mot c'est
le contrôle du corps des femmes est là
c'est assez
c'est terrible de voir notre église qui
se base sur ce qui est arrivé depuis 200
ans et lutte des femmes pour obtenir que
non seulement elle et des droits de vote
et droit civil et l'instruction à
égalité donc l'accès au savoir mais
surtout cette révolution décor une houle
sur m aujourd'hui de nos corps et
l'église continue d'interdire la
contraception
elle interdit l'avortement même en cas
de viol et elles luttent toujours pour
que les femmes soient contrôlés et alors
et j'ai vu ali chami que vous vous
réclamez une réforme du droit canon
alors vous allez m'expliquer brièvement
de quoi il s'agit vous dit en fait que
les femmes sont instrumentalisés par les
hommes d'église qu'on nie leur capacité
de responsabilité et donc vous demander
une réforme de ce droit canon expliquez
nous oui alors une vraie vie je ne sais
pas si je demande une réforme à vos vous
valent rien
vous souhaitez le seul moyen pour
l'église de changer c'est pas de faire
un synode nous on va changer de la
pastorale entre guillemets tout en ne
voulant pas changer la doctrine ce qui à
mon avis il n'a pas beaucoup de sens
je voulais effectivement deux canons qui
me paraissent représentait vraiment le
barrage est le nom qui fait que les
femmes sont à favoriser dans l'église le
premier c'est le canon mais 24
seul un homme baptisé reçoit validement
l'ordination sacrée
donc on a beaucoup de choses là dedans
c'est un homme les femmes sont exclues
sans qu'on en dise en creux on ne parle
pas d'elle et l'ordination sacrée c'est
à dire qu on signifie bien que les
femmes n'ont pas accès au sacré ne
peuvent pas être médiateur du sacré et
n'auront pas accès à l'école à à l'hôtel
pardon le deuxième c'est curieusement il
est lié marion mais c'est la conséquence
de celui là il dit seuls les ordonner
sont capables d'exercer le pouvoir de
gouvernement dans l'église est bien le
mot capable très intéressante parce que
il ya le mot chef de dans le maux de
tête
et effectivement les hommes sans la tête
et les femmes sans décor et on retrouve
ça dans les autres régions
malheureusement et donc elles n'ont pas
la capacité de gouverner d'avenir dans
le documentaire un moment vous dites
pour faire avancer les religions il faut
passer par une remise en question des
transferts traditionnel séder termes
empruntés à la psychanalyse à la
psychologie qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là je pense qu'il faut être capable
de repenser les notions de masculins et
deux féminins pour pas les laisser être
enfermé dans les problématiques de
différences de sexe alors aujourd'hui
ces questions de genre elles font peur
elles font pas peur simplement ou pensée
religieuse on voit qu'elles font peur à
la société en général à la société
française
mais je pense que c'est une urgence de
repenser ses questions
traditionnellement dans les textes le
féminin est toujours associé à une
notion de perte de contrôle une notion
de vulnérabilité alors que le masculin
est associé à une notion justement de
contrôler d'autonomie du corps et de la
pensée alors je crois que bien dans nos
textes on trouve bien
souvent cette idée que chacun d'entre
nous un mot femme on est capable
d'expérimenter ou pour une autre vie des
mamans de masculinité et des moins de
féminité sinon si on suit ses attributs
du genre je crois qu'aujourd'hui à une
urgence à ce que les pensées religieuses
soient capables de penser avec un peu
plus de complexité
ces notions parce que sinon on sera
constamment renvoyer hommes et femmes
aux attributs aux attributs
traditionnels de nos gens râlent
épousailles pour les femmes j'ai une
question précise à vous poser farid
aloui ce qui est étonnant dans l'islam
c'est que l'islam a connu des périodes
très différentes
il ya eu un âge d'or vers neuvième
siècle un temps marqué par une grande
liberté de moeurs
la première femme du prophète khadija
était une femme puissante les femmes
avaient accès à la politique à la guerre
elle pouvait prier près des hommes et
petit à petit elles ont disparu de
l'espace public
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce que
c'était une influence d'autres religions
monothéistes qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est le retard
de l'islam
c'est ce que je m'explique je sais c'est
le retard de l'islam c'est que dans la
modernité et l'islam ne se sont pas
rencontrés et à chaque fois il ya eu des
tentatives et malheureusement les
tentatives ont échoué
je veux pas refaire l'histoire est là
c'est ça devient mais c'est bien armé
pour revenir à ce que d'abord il y a
dans l'imaginaire de de l'islam ya un
problème il ya un problème qui incarne
psychanalyste musulmans la traiter à
merveille c'est que le prophète n'a pas
eu tort et moi j'ai une thèse c'est que
le prophète
vraiment j'ai une thèse très
sérieusement ça il voulait on ne sait
pas ce qui s'est passé à la mort du
prophète quand il voulait écrire son
testament
on ne lui a pas laissé qu'ils l'écrivent
il était très attaché à sa fille ce sas
sa cadette faute et b qui voulaient bien
en face au na pas eu des mines a pas eu
de fils inapte à valence exactement et
dans le coran qui sont morts oui à
prendre à un genre du pont et on l'a
traité de captage c'est à dire celui qui
ne peut pas avoir deux fils c'est à dire
bon et il y a dans le coran une sourate
qui dit attaché c'est vous les humains
j'ai eu beaucoup d'abondance le
alarme a donné l'abondance pourquoi ne
pas interpréter cette abondance par
beaucoup de filles c'est toute
interprétation est ouverte
voyez alors pour revient à ce que vous
disiez d'abord dans l'imaginaire des
musulmans c'est l'amour que le prophète
ab pour ses filles notamment pour sa
première épouse sandra designer il n'y
aurait pas eu de demande m il faut pas
se leurrer et ça même les historiens
sérieux le reconnaissent je veux dire
sans cette femme il n'y aurait pas eu d'
islam donc déjà ça il faudrait au
remettre ça en question au coeur des de
l'islam premièrement deuxièmement
pourquoi le retard et d'expliquer que
l'islam n'a pas pu rencontrer la
modernité et à partir de là tout est
parti toute la tradition de le gêner
dans la baie de sape de spécial à
l'islam ces exemples principe l'islam se
transmet par les pairs par les hommes
alors que le judaïsme en principe mais
avec beaucoup d'exceptions avec beaucoup
déception c'est plutôt par les mères à
temps ce qu'il faut voir aussi pour
d'autres confessions dans le
protestantisme tous les pasteurs étaient
hommes avant mais les femmes de pasteur
faisait le catéchisme c'est à dire
l'école de dimanche et ancenis
puisqu'elles font l'école du dimanche
pourquoi ne deviendrait pas parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui dans le
catholicisme la plupart des catéchistes
sont des femmes un jour on va se poser
cette question là mais chaque religion a
une histoire particulière qui
effectivement justifie à une époque
donnée que la place des femmes n'ait pas
été la même et aujourd'hui la place de
la femme devrait être la même que celle
de l'homme partout et d'ailleurs d'un
final et là on entend dans le
documentaire l'interprétation des textes
que vous faites et notamment votre
analyse de la genèse qui est très
intéressante où vous dites si l'on est
fidèle à l'hébreu on ne traduit pas eve
est née de la côte d'adam mais eve est
né à côté d'adam quand vous livrer une
interprétation comme celle ci comment
elle est reçue je crois qu'elle ne peut
qu être reçu par les zébras par les gens
qui ne peuvent reconnaître que
effectivement l'hébreu ne parle pas
d'une côte mais d'un côté ce qui change
tout que si elle est sortie à côté de ce
2 a donc qui d'ailleurs était en réalité
by jean ray puisque adam est créé dans
la genèse au chapitre dans laquelle
masculin et féminin donc ça veut bien
dire et les commentateurs insistent sur
le fait qu au sein d'un même corps il y
adeux gens à l'origine et puis tout à
coup chapitre de la genèse l'histoire
est racontée différemment ce adam c'est
à dire cette humanité donne naissance
baroque ce qui est presque un
accouchement finalement à une femme qui
lui fait face et qui est à côté de lui
et c'est pas du tout la même chance
d'être à côté de ce premier rhum ou
d'être sa cote c'est un élément de
soutien
si vous êtes à côté vous pouvez
entretenir un rapport sujet à ce sujet
si vous êtes sa cote vous n'êtes que
dans un rapport sujet objet ou élément
de soutien et il ya encore quelque chose
de très important c'est qu'il ya pas
seulement le sexy elle degré de parenté
gardant beaucoup de religions par
exemple bon mettons les prêtres peuvent
pas se marier n'est pas peuvent pas se
marier les vénérables bouddhiste peuvent
pas se marier bon ils ont des neveux
c'est le népotisme et on va transmettre
le pouvoir donc la 9e sexe ou pas sexy
n'a pas besoin oui ce que je dis donc en
réalité je crois vous avez raison ce qui
est premier c'est le pouvoir ce qui est
second c'est l'argent et ce qui est
seulement troisième c'est le sexe je
reviens sur cette interprétation la
jeunesse parce que l'ancien testament et
donc la jeunesse d'un texte commun aux
juifs et aux chrétiens
est ce qu'une interprétation comme celle
ci sentant chez les chrétiens oui tout à
fait mais les problèmes de traduction de
l'hébreu sont innombrables et si vous
prenez la version grecque des 70 on a
encore d'autres problèmes de traduction
mais même si on reprend la traduction
habituel eve est sorti de la côte d'adam
ça n'en fait absolument pas un être
inférieur
le fait qu'on en fasse un être inférieur
c'est parce qu'on cherche à tout prix à
trouver une interprétation bien
infériorité cette interprétation est ce
que comme on l'entend dans le
documentaire sa part excès de textos
sterone c'est à dire est ce que parce
que ces textes ont été lus traduit et
réécrit par des hommes au fur et à
mesure des siècles et bien c'est c'est
ça oui on peut dire ça et en asie si on
peut dire que l'église catholique a une
tradition d'exégèse assez faible quand
on fait un peu d'hébreu est collé un
petit peu d'exigences juive
tout en étant très modeste on voit bien
l'immense distance qu'il ya entre la
capacité des que les huiles et la
capacité exégèse catholique et l'église
catholique est bloqué par son gros
canons partout ces textes et elle
n'arrive pas à nous quand on a travaillé
tous ces textes là on a vu que revenait
toujours le même texte est toujours la
même interprétation donc l'appel à
l'église et de dire relisant le texte je
suis pas tout à fait alors il ya eu
notamment sur la jeunesse des livres
d'un jj qui s'appelle paul beauchamp
extrêmement ouvert sur création et c'est
pareil avec les blessés et il n'était
pas le seul mais simplement c'est
jésuites l'ann e ou ses exégètes ne sont
pas suivies par on a du mal à les
laisser entendre
on va poursuivre je vous répondrais
écoute un autre règle est que pendant
extrait du documentaire où vous dites
dès qu'une chose de très important au
delà 1 du rapport homme femme
il y a le rapport à l'autre on réécoute
en fait il me semble que ce qu'enfin ce
que j'ai fait à explorer dans le livre
c'est qu'en réalité la femme c'est le
féminin dans les textes et le féminin il
représente toujours l'autre c'est la
figure de l'altérité en général qui est
incarnée par la femme donc l'autre pose
problème parce qu'on le perçoit comme
quelque chose de menaçant qui menace
votre identité qui menace votre vos
frontières
est ce qu'aujourd'hui alors que notre
société est meurtri par la haine de soi
donc par la haine de l'autre
on a perdu une certaine conscience de
l'autre défi narnia je crois que c'est
la question du moment où on fait lequel
on fait face aujourd'hui dans les drames
qu'on est en train de vivre moi je suis
très troublé par les slogans qu'on a
tous repris où la plupart d'entre nous
se je suis juif je suis musulman je suis
journaliste
c'est intéressant cette capacité tout à
coup d'affichés qu'on peut être l'autre
qu'on peut avoir mal avec lui mais cette
slogan est en fait il est haï à double
sens parce que est ce que ça signifie
que je ne peux avoir mal avec l'autre
que si je me mets à sa place en fait
l'enjeu d'une vraie société empathique
c'est d'être capable de dire je suis
avec lui alors que je ne suis pas dans
sa peau alors qu'il est extérieur à moi
et pour moi l'enjeu il est loin d'être
capable de dire je souffre avec l'autre
juif musulman etc
même si je ne suis pas flammes et est ce
que au delà qu'on soit croyant ou non on
peut entendre une passerelle comme l'a
fait
emmanuel levinas et en son temps dira
qu' il ya la trace de dieu dans l'autre
et si l'on ne croit pas juste qu'on est
responsable de l'autre odon vallet oui
c'est possible mais vous savez chaque
pays en particulier à la france et 1 %
du monde donc ne réduisons pas le monde
à la france est incontestablement il ya
un retour à l'identitaire religieux en
france depuis un certain nombre d'années
vous savez que j'ai créé la plus
importante fondation au monde en matière
d'éducation germi quarante cinq mille
bourses en 15 ans notamment au vietnam
au bénin je vous assure que ces jeunes
sont de toutes les régions j'ai même des
séminaristes catholique mais j'ai des
bouddhistes et des communistes
j'ai des musulmans g etc il s'entend
tous bien entre eux au bénin toutes les
religions s'entendent bien il ya aucun
problème
il ne faut surtout pas croire que ce que
nous avons vécu en france depuis
quelques années peut-être encore pire
depuis c'est horrible attentat ce soit
quelque chose de général dans la planète
je note au contraire dans certains pays
dans certains continents notamment en
asie en asie une ouverture beaucoup plus
grande à l'égalité des sexes et surtout
une tolérance beaucoup plus grande à
l'égard des religions des autres y
compris dans des pays communistes qui
n'étaient pas en principe ouvert à la
religion et qui était athée c'est en
train de changer en chine c'est en train
de changer au vietnam ne réduisons pas
la planète à notre petit pays qui fait 0
8% de la population mondiale
certainement pas mais on disait les
femmes est problématique quand même la
france peut porter certaines à l'arrêt
dans certains pays très sympa
l'église n'a pas pris en compte cela et
l'égalité pour elle n'est pas une
lunette dont elle se sert elle se sert
de l'inégalité et c'est quand même
l'égalité qui est la lunette qui permet
de voir les violences contre les femmes
qui sont si nombreuses et donc et c'est
internationale s'est effectivement
france on a l'air d'être un peu plus
protégé
quoique une femme meurt tous les trois
jours donc si vous voulez l'église ne
voit pas les teintes différentes aux
femmes et pourquoi pas ce qu'elle a
cette lunette de l'inégalité des rôles
sur une religion le pire des pires web
promet aux femmes qu'on fait aux femmes
c'est le meurtre des foetus féminins
c'est à dire que en chine au vietnam en
inde
on a cent treize naissances de garçons
pour
en essence de filles il ya 13 foetus
féminins qui sont tués or aucune
religion ni bouddhiste ni hindouiste ni
chrétienne ni musulmane n'a vraiment
essayé de lutter contre eux c'est
terrible c'était un meurtre par millions
chaque année dont presque personne ne
pas aucune religion ne fait rien contre
je trouve je lisais que malek chebel qui
est un autre intellectuel aussi
anthropologue spéciale de l'islam disait
que l'islam doctrinal néglige la place
de l'individu qui l'obligent à se fondre
en elle pour survivre est ce que ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui l'islam là où il est
n'arrive pas à penser l'individu
l'individualité part du sujet de
craindre la personne les islams
officielle parce que bon il ya des
islams mais disons effectivement les
islams officiel où l'islam officiel
absolument et contre l'individu je veux
dire même en dans le ster politique on
parle de consensus c'est hallucinant à
quel point on n'arrive pas à faire
comprendre mais même chez les
intellectuels musulmans ils veulent
absolument qu'on soit d'accord parce
qu'ils pensent que le consensus et la
paix alors qu'au contraire justement
c'est la démocratie c'est j'accepte que
de ne pas être d'accord avec toi l'islam
a beaucoup de mal avec sa part la
tradition politique et par la tradition
religieuse l'islam officiel encore une
fois mais comme l'a dit delphine à aller
voir dans l'ésotérisme de l'islam
vous savez des merveilles de ça vous
avez la féminisation 12 b roll qui dit
le dieu émanations on est parent
révélation est l'émanation c'est la
femme parce que cela crée de la créature
la plus belle du monde
il a faim il a carrément et dit dieu et
femmes donc vous avez également sa et
ses traditions là sont très puissants
dans de nombreux pays
mais effectivement là aussi ça viendra
moderne avec le ce que je vous disais
cette fermeture
face à la modernité c'est la modernité
un des piliers de la modernité c'est là
la lahb sortir des
des croyances superstitieuses accepté
l'individu est acceptée effectivement
quelque part le néant accepté également
des tracts et accepter d'être agnostique
à fond tout ça c'est c'est quelque chose
qui fait hélas aujourd'hui ça
aujourd'hui ça dépend de quoi ça dépend
ça veut dire que l'islam attend ses
propres lumières ou qu'on ne laisse pas
émergé comme la cause mais sur les
générations qui arrivent parce que ce
qu'on ne dit pas aussi assez mais on est
un petit peu évoquée c'est que les
jeunes dans le monde musulman beaucoup
plus attirés par le modèle de l'occident
que par le modèle
donc est ce que c'est il ya une réaction
il ya également cesser un mouvement qui
n'a pas pris encore et j'espère que ça
prendra j'espère vraiment comme le
disait delphine moi je pense que dans le
monde musulman
il faudrait pour les croyants et pour
les non croyants
il faudrait effectivement réinterpréter
le texte tout en disant qu'il ya
d'autres traditions il yad'autres ya le
voir avec un une étude comparative avec
la philosophie mais effectivement vous
savez moi quand je vais dans des dans
des banlieues à problèmes je suis allé
plusieurs fois j'ai des bambins comme ça
qu'ils viennent avec la réaction au
début et petit à petit quand je leur
parle en tant que musulmane et quand ils
disent est ce que tu es croyant ou non
je dis ça ça ne regarde pas mais en tout
cas je pense que je connais un peu plus
un peu mieux mahomet que toi et quand je
leur parle avec les textes en me
référant aux textes musulmans y peuvent
pas me dire vas t'en toi s'attend ce
dental où je sais et à la fin le gamin
j'ai eu au moins deux gamins de 9 à 12
ans qui m'ont dit alors on peut dire à
notre imam que c'est absolument pas
obligatoire dans l'islam de portel fin
la gd oui et tu me l'envoie si tu es que
l'origine du voile c'est la tablette à
40 attribuée au roi tu es glatch
thalassa premier roi d'assyrie mille ans
avant jésus-christ qui impose jeunes
filles pubères à partir de 13 ans de
porter le voile pour montrer qu'elles
sont promises à un époux et toutes les
autres sont des prostituées
ça a été maintenue ensuite dans l'islam
c'est elle maintenue dans le catholique
dans le christianisme primitif la
tradition du voile est antérieure de
1700 en eau
refaites mohamed et aux livres du camp
comme beaucoup d'autre à dire donc c'est
pour terminer c'est juste pour dire
qu'effectivement l'islam à sa
traditionnelle des lumières à ccc
ces pontes j'allais dire ces grands
hommes
on a on n'a qu'à revenir dessus et ça
c'est un travail à faire et c'est
qu'avec les musulmans mais quelque part
ce que vous êtes en train de dire aussi
c'est que la femme et on le voit dans
certains pays du monde musulman
aujourd'hui un rôle à jouer aux côtés
des imams auprès des jeunes dans la
prévention contre la radicalisation
bien sûr et ça peut être une avancée
justement de la place de la femme
certainement et la jeunesse dont vous
avez parlé je termine là dessus ça pose
pour moi c'est mon grand espoir parce
qu'il ya une jeunesse qui par réaction
rejettent ils peuvent être alors ils
tombent dans l'autre grand notamment il
ya une haine de tout ce qui est un tout
vient du centre
la ccc c'est l'islam c'est ce que dit
effectivement ces gens là c'est c'est la
violence etc
et il y a une autre jeunesse qui au
contraire tout tout en n'étant pas
forcément croyant recherche
cette identité entre l'ira lité et
l'islamité recherche cette identité au
moins en grand je pense que ce mouvement
est un peu valables dans pas mal
d'autres pays musulmans
et cette jeunesse est là et à mon avis
est la clé est la clé la clé ouais
delphine horvilleur vous dit le rabbin
et dans un voyage permanent des émotions
contraires un voyage de traduction entre
les textes et des hommes
est ce que le guide religieux spirituel
aujourd'hui doit être plus que jamais
dans la vie de sa communauté et les
accompagner dans leurs difficultés du
quotidien plus proche du réel
jeudi il n'ya pas de clergé donc très
clairement le rabbin il est pas dans une
fonction d'intermédiaire entre la
personne et le divin simplement il peut
faciliter sa mesure l'accès aux textes
et je crois que aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont dans une
demande d'avoir accès au texte une
demande de savoir et la voix des femmes
allaient particulièrement critique
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai la conviction
quand les hommes et les femmes étudient
ensemble quelque chose dans la tradition
religieuse et fertiliser dans le
discours et c'est à ce moment là que le
texte peut encore dire qu'il révèle
qu'il n'a pas dit une fois pour toutes
pour moi l'image à utiliser
l'âge du voile à nouveau dont on parlait
il ya un instant je pense que c'est pas
les femmes qu'il faut voilée c'est le
texte quand je dis vous allez le tac je
veux dire par là une prise de conscience
qu' une lecture publique passe par la
conscience de tout un chacun que le
texte n'a pas tout montrer de lui-même
qu'il n'a pas tout dit que quelque chose
de lui ai caché et qu'on a besoin de
lecture nouvelle métabolisé par la
modernité par des situations
contemporaines pour pouvoir révéler le
texte à nouveau ajoutons que bien sûr le
rabbin serra bis et lemaitre que nous
avons eu tous des maîtres d'école mais
aussi des maîtresses d'école
qu'aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
enseignants sont des femmes et je pense
que dans l'avenir la place des femmes
dans les religions sera plus importante
parce que les jeunes ont de plus en plus
de profs femmes
à tel point que ça pose parfois un
problème puisque moi qui présidait jurys
du bac
je connais des élèves de terminale qui
n'a aucun prof sommes donc ça sera la
stas renversant mais je pense que dans
l'avenir puisque on a tous des
maîtresses des pros femmes la position
uniquement masculine du clergé va
devenir intenable ali chami oui l'église
doit se positionner très vite dans
l'église catholique
je parle de l'église catholique parce
que c'est le sujet que j'ai travaillé et
de se positionner très vite parce que
malgré tout les femmes partent
aujourd'hui les femmes qui aujourd'hui
font vivre les paroisses qui est
tellement de travail ne les paroisses
puis qu'il ya assez peu de prêtres
elles sont de ma génération les aurait
que vatican ii ils ont été motivées par
vatican ii mais on l'a on leur a retiré
leurs responsabilités tout en leur
laissant travail et je ne crois pas
qu'il y aura de relève
c'est une relève qui qui qui est qui est
beaucoup plus petit qui est beaucoup
plus réactionnaires qui par exemple s'il
y avait une évolution sur l'ordination
des femmes
est-ce que c'est envisageable que
l'ordination des femmes je sais que dans
le droit canon elle a été notamment
l'interdiction était inscrit dessus si
je ne me trompe d'une manière pas en 82
mois par jean paul ii est-ce qu'on peut
revenir là dessus je pense que pour le
moment c'est impossible a pensé pour eux
tant qu'ils n'auront pas fait une
révolution intellectuelle sur l'égalité
l'égalité c'est pas un mythe l'égalité
est un opérateur de penser comme le dit
geneviève fraisse et c'est ça qui permet
de penser autrement et de revenir à
relire les textes autres avant et si
vous lisez
samaritaine comme on l'a lu dans notre
livre et quand vous l'entendez dit par
un prêtre
il ya un monde et donc je rejoins
delphine et je vous écoute je voulais
juste dire et vous vous le savez mieux
que moi beaucoup mieux que moi c'est ça
c'est honteux
un ca avant les religions c'était les
philosophes c'était pareil géré la
misogynie ccc à sa date de sa des
racines et il faut pas oublier notre le
toutou l'héritage de l'hellénisme sur
une religion ou le savez mieux que moi
c'est donc il faut repenser tout ça moi
je suis ravi vous êtes en minorité pour
la pour l'armée en général regarder une
déjà nous plateau c'est ce que je dis à
chaque fois je suis je suis honoré
d'être parfois la seule femme
on aurait entre guillemets mais à chaque
fois je dis mais pourquoi pourquoi où il
n'ya pas de femme aussi intelligente que
les sommes que vous êtes et vous vous
vous voyez donc ça va très très loin il
faut revenir un peu à tous les
philosophes antiques il y avait deux
philosophes et on les a bien écarté bien
bien écartées il faut revenir à
réellement comme l a dit si on veut
arriver à l'égalité c'est dans tous
l'espèrent partout et la religion est
effectivement très important parce que
c'est l'autorité l'autorité religieuse
de la religion et se poser la question
de pourquoi l'érudition féminine elle
est acceptée dans tant de domaines enfin
tout cas beaucoup plus que dans le monde
religieux les gens effectivement des
enseignants des profs d'université des
médecins des chirurgiens femme ça leur
pose pas de problème mais dès qu'on
passe la porte de l'institution
religieuse alors là on entrerait dans un
monde digne du musée où devrait être
derrière une vitre d'être une salle
c'est pas venu chasseurs du jour sio
mais aujourd'hui eh oui il ya une
cohérence simplement à un sujet dans ce
domaine ça ce pool le pouvoir est
beaucoup plus important voyez fait on
n'a pratiquement pas parlé une
confession c'est l'orthodoxie
seuls les hommes peuvent être prêt tout
évêque par contre il ya les femmes
monial qui sont souvent d'une
remarquable intelligence qui joue un
rôle je dirais et philosophiques ou
théologique est relativement important
mais ces femmes malheureusement n'ont
guère de pouvoir également de rien
je pense que les églises d'orient seront
obligés de faire leur révolution
comme l'église de rond mais je voudrais
vous appuyer pour dire qu'effectivement
des religieuses en particulier les
religieuses américaines qui se sont
rassemblés pour réfléchir pour produire
des textes pour pour essayer de féconder
cette religion qui est qui qui n'est pas
dans la modernité non plus et en fait
elles se font vraiment humiliée je
verrai et je voudrais juste rajouter que
les religieuses ne font pas partie des
clercs sont dans la catégorie mon but
c'est le coeur régulier et le clergé
séculier alors le combat sera encore
long merci à tous d'être venus sur ce
plateau si vous voulez poursuit
l'infection art d'abord le roman de
fariba hachtroudi le colonel et la paca
temps 55 chez albin michel le déni ali
chablis mode amandiers voilà et puis il
ya aussi le livre de delphine horvilleur
que je n'ai pas qu'ils s'appellent en
tenue d'eve
et puis aussi une revue que delphine
horvilleur dirige qui s'appelle ténois
dieu at-il de l'humour cette semaine
merci à tous la semaine prochaine je
vous retrouve une nouvelle fois cette
fois nous parlerons de l'engagement en
politique chez les élus locaux
à très vite sur public sénat